we do have time for just a couple more
calls let's go to our next caller here
from the nine one eight area code if you
will indulge me Pat we will talk to our
nine one eight caller caller what's your
name and where you're calling from uh
then from Oklahoma awesome what's your
question today my question is um you
know how there's a lot of debate from
like the Civil War like what actually
was because of it was it slavery what is
your take on that in what sense is there
a lot of debate like where are you
hearing the debate about that well
typically one from the south so a lot of
people my view on it you know the Maine
no matter how you slice it invites it it
was slavery but especially for where I'm
at a lot of people want to deny that it
was slavery because I feel like they
don't want to admit that you know our
past you know you know fought their
lives for slavery and I always hear
people but they did whether it was
slavery or not and I'm just curious what
your take on that is I do think it was
slavery but I think the fascinating
thing is Pat that in Massachusetts
there's not much debate about what the
Civil War was about so it's very
interesting that you said you were from
Oklahoma right yeah yeah in Oklahoma
people are debating it so I guess when
Trump said people haven't been able to
figure this out yet
I guess he maybe is referring to states
like Oklahoma where I guess there's a
debate yeah and a lot of people who
support the Confederacy try to make the
argument that the Civil War was a lot
more about states rights but the natural
follow-up question to that is a state's
right to do what yet and it is a case
way to enslave people then we're back to
the original premise hey do people in
Oklahoma get like if you say if there's
someone that doesn't believe it was a
war about slavery and you come in and
you say I think it was about slavery can
it get ugly
um kind of because like there I guess
where you're from it's not but like you
know especially here and I guess you
know state phenomena it is a really big
debate and a lot of people do say it's
not and people can get pretty heated and
about it you know how common are
Confederate flag as I've always liked
how comment on I'll soon um of course
and I've heard a lot I don't think I've
seen as much but I have seen them like
and with people on the cars they're not
too common but they do they are there
but it is pretty common for people to to
also debate that the flag is racist or
not so that is a big debate here the
other if it's racist flag then it's like
you know histories heritage and all that
stuff
I mean Oklahoma is not even really the
south it's important for us to know that
this is a debate in Oklahoma still so I
appreciate you telling us that hope to
speak to you again thanks for the call I
appreciate it